Deflation is literally
just a lowering of prices,
or a general
decrease in the level
of prices for
goods and services.
Or another way to think
about it, since inflation
is an increase in
the level of prices,
you can just view it
as negative inflation.
And so, let's say we're the
folks at the Bureau of Labor
Statistics, and we're trying
to compute the CPI index.
And in one period-- let's call
this period one over here--
we have our CPI index
for urban consumers.
And that's the one
that's quoted most often.
And we have this
basket of goods.
And it'll have housing in it.
Let me write that a
little bit neater.
It'll have housing in it.
It'll have transportation in it.
It'll have a fuel in it.
It might have some
proxy for entertainment
or whatever else inside of it.
And that basket of goods,
let's say in period one--
and this is a
simplification-- runs
that urban consumer
on average $100.
And then we go to
period two, and we
look at that same
basket of goods.
Maybe we're adjusting
certain things,
maybe some products
have become obsolete
and we have to
replace, or there has
to be some adjustments
for technology.
And that's all under debate,
how you should adjust them.
But given that,
assuming everything else
is equal, that same basket of
goods is now running at $98.
And so the total cost
of goods and services
for this kind of average
consumer has gone down by $2.
Or we could say that
we've experienced
negative 2% inflation,
which is really
just another way of saying that
we have experienced deflation.
Now, deflation is not
the norm, especially
for growing economies,
the way that
our current economic systems
runs, although it does happen.
And Japan in
particular is probably
the most recent, most
famous case of deflation.
And the main reason
why economists really
don't like deflation-- or
I should say in particular,
while central bankers really
don't like deflation--
is that it makes it much
harder to control the economy
or to fuel the economy
with interest rates
alone, or actually just
with printing money alone.
And I'll go into a
little bit more depth
with that in future videos.
One thing I do
want to make clear
is although deflation
isn't what we normally
see in the broader
economy as a whole,
it does happen very frequently
in specific sectors.
And the most common one is
in the technology sector,
specifically hardware.
We've all experienced buying
a laptop at one period--
so right now you buy the
laptop for maybe $1,000--
and then six months
later you see
that exact same laptop for $500.
And that's just because the
rate of technological innovation
is going so fast
that they can produce
the same amount of memory
and processing power
for a lot cheaper now.
Or for the same
amount of money you
can get much more memory
and processing power,
and all of the rest.
And you see this with laptops
and with a big screen TVs
and phones and all the rest.